[Music]
in no manners news oh this is definitely
how do you know submitted by he has a
racist radar oh this is so sad
submitted by purple giraffe but they
misspelled xerath a lot not even like a
cuz a lot of ways the [ __ ] that [ __ ]
there's that is J IRA Fe you know you
tried though so yeah and I'm almost and
don't even say that you're trying to be
creative with it cuz that's definitely
wasn't it oh yeah yeah triple gyrase a
woman puts a man on blasts were
repeatedly spitting on the train [ __ ]
spits in the train for Chinese people
yes they do
really why supplies I mean I knew
mainlanders be paying and stuff okay so
honk I know how don't don't kill me guys
I know Hong Kong and Taiwan is totally
different from mainland China and the
culture is totally different but when I
was in Hong Kong and we were walking
down the street this dude [ __ ] wet
like and just shot out [ __ ] nostril
[ __ ] anyway bah and I was like what the
[ __ ]
ok I'm okay with someone Hocking a
loogie and spitting on the floor no
problem right it is nasty but it happens
I have yet to see anybody go by and just
[ __ ] perfectly shoot and go by and
then the other [ __ ] and she doesn't need
a white anything so clean just oh like
damn dude it's like a [ __ ] nose
trumpet ya know they state a reminder
that gets like for summary but when you
say that I picture like spider-man's web
you know I was mind blown that's but at
least it's on the street
even people here they spit on the street
whatever is the street right inside of a
[ __ ] train that's nasty
I can't believe that that's biological
warfare I don't even think people would
do that anywhere
well this man did it in Shanghai what
what what what is where is Shanghai
I think that Arizona okay Shanghai
Arizona yeah here we go here's the he's
not a Shanghai Street [ __ ] nasty
uh-uh she's yelling at him yeah
this is if I was the boss I would have
kicked you out or some point down go
girl
why she she's dancing
so what she's saying is even mainland
aren't mainlanders or mainlanders on
mainland so what I mean by that is like
you know how like Taiwan and Hong Kong
may feel like they're not part of like
mainland China China is so huge there's
also different parts so in Shanghai
Beijing like there's places that are
considered classy and for her what she's
saying is that you're in Shanghai right
now you have to act right this is one of
the most international cities in the
world don't act like that over here even
if you're a [ __ ] villager don't come
to Shanghai yeah don't act like a
villager in shame oh good good watch
this fool though is good on a change
[ __ ] is wrong with him is it this isn't
your house
yeah
this is like cleaning up after me like
just like the artists bus game you're a
[ __ ] villager don't act like this is
Shanghai accountability China but then
it is Shanghai it's almost like a
mainlander going to Hong Kong and
spitting in the train yeah like it they
they're not gonna be cool with that
that's awesome just to put it in
perspective is that we were talking
about - which is why I think it's okay
for as Asian people to kind of check
other Asian people like yo just cuz
you're from that area like that's cool
if you do in your area but you got to
realize when you come some other place -
you got to follow those rules just like
when white people like white Americans
is what I mean like white Americans and
there's a lot of articles that we read
where they go and they disrespect parts
of Asia they should know the same [ __ ] -
you know so also applies for Asian
people when they go other places - I'm
saying yeah it's all about
accountability and you know being
responsible for each other
yeah cuz that [ __ ] was disgusting that
for as she was y'all you go oh he's like
I'll show you Beach no grab them by the
back with two things he was saying
something something Ethan and that's all
I understood hmm Ethier was any little
bit something like that right and then
they said that lady was saying a tea
party samosas on some a tea fund or I
think that one is these are my seat
puffs so that's some of the fun that
means I I heard I know
so somebody vom means like in which
place so surprise came like in which
place do you [ __ ] act like this do
you spit like this in which place Tommy
I can't believe you got it I've been a
China for like three month and Renault
[ __ ] day so I picked up a few words
[Laughter]
that's time okay
cuz I mean yeah she's right Shanghai is
an international metropolitan it's kind
of like Hong Kong it was a territory of
the Portuguese or the Dutch or I forgot
it was an International shipping
destination like back and back back back
back before it was given back to China
or whatever I think they're more like
modern and classy and and they don't
represent like the culture of I guess in
mainland China I know there's a conflict
between the city folk and then the
Beverly hillbilly villagers that are
coming into the city and taking a poopoo
inside of the Train and all that so they
probably hate that like this isn't this
is people go oh you're mainlander you
come from Beijing you come from Shanghai
and that's like misrepresenting who they
are it is it is a huge vestment
misrepresentation yeah because when I
made friends out in the Beijing he was
born or raised here but he was teaching
at the university there he was teaching
English and in we all went to go visit
him and all of his friends from the
University there were classical music
majors they were like just regular
students just like us and but they came
from classy families then so this whole
like stereotype about mainland Chinese I
had no idea I had zero idea that they
peed and poot all over the floor cuz I
didn't see that in Beijing yeah I didn't
see any of that until
yeah until you know all this [ __ ]
started happening in the States and I
was like for some reason like just
somewhere I want to visit do you know
what be a really dope trip no sports
this time I think that's [ __ ] great
go yourself and send me some pictures
[ __ ] yeah I mean I'll load it like
Singapore the only place I want to go is
like if there's a helicopter and just
drop me off at the Forbidden City or
Great Wall of China and then take you
and [ __ ] like rescue my ass out of
there I want to go through the city I'll
do that [ __ ] I just put me there and
then evacuate mass yeah it's not bad
it's kind of cool I I remember this
whole mall was full of counterfeit [ __ ]
so imagine going to a shop shopping mall
in every single store is counterfeit and
I got like colored you supported it you
know how poor I was at that time I was
rich enough to afford a ticket but a
five-dollar collared shirt was dope
that's a really good five dollar echo
shirt oh yeah can button-up yeah that's
true
that'd have been like 40 bucks or fifty
bucks back then nobody could tell the
difference even I can't refuse a good
deal I still kept some of that [ __ ] it's
probably something the problem - yes the
Shanghai Metro operator said that the
offender in the video is facing a 500
yuan fine which comes out to about $73
it's good you should [ __ ] face that
should you [ __ ] yeah and the operator
also encouraged other citizens to do the
same defuse Emily this is not acceptable
yeah cuz it goes I feel like once they
understand like what's okay then they
would teach others and then when they
travel the world they'll have better
manners and cuz like most people can't
tell agents apart yeah I couldn't tell
anybody on the train apart and tell that
until that dude started spitting on the
floor I know you're like ah [ __ ] you
know like let's say someone in France
runs into these like [ __ ]
Neanderthals right and then they're all
spitting all over the train their mind
is like now burned that Asians are dirty
[ __ ] yeah and then it's like that's not
a representation of all of us dude [ __ ]
not another thing that people from Japan
Oh like that Korea like that everywhere
so we all got to get together and have a
Asian huddle and be like check this out
dude
a being poor doesn't mean
have to be [ __ ] disgusting that's
crazy though too because that just shows
the level of confidence some of these
mainlanders have they go to another
country like these are my rules be
another name because no matter what
country I go to I try to be as conscious
as possible about what what's going on
around me you know what it means so this
is these are people who are too
confident I think they're just ignorant
and uneducated and they don't know the
world and they're just getting exposure
it's like you don't have any education
you're [ __ ] rich as hell and you have
access to the world but you didn't get
educated it's like what I have I like
how they banded together and they kick
his ass out yeah that foot probably got
off the trailer was like I'm gonna buy
this chain [ __ ]
he looked over stuff okay hello matter
people do you want to contact me and
everybody else you see go ahead and
check the description box below and
follow our social medias is the Gramps
and Twitter's for more videos click up
there baby
[Music]